my compadre from NFL Network and a
three-time Super Bowl champion Willie
joins me here on the show how are you
Willie I'm fine walk me through what
Belichick is like this week Steelers
week coming off a loss like the one they
suffered in Miami Willie what's he like
right now
well basically he wants to put the whole
Miami debacle behind them he wants these
guys the funkiest kind of hit the reset
button then they try to get them
understand the magnitude of this game
there's a lot of Corrections that's
going on and you know that defense I
played great you know during the eight
game winning streak and a lot of
different categories a lot of different
critical areas that there wasn't playing
well in the beginning of the season so
I'm sure there's been a lot of
Corrections going on and a lot of
adjustments going on this week so what
are the adjustments what did you see
from the Dolphins what they were able to
do obviously Kenyan Drake was a matchup
nightmare that would think that levy on
bail will be the same there were a lot
of crossing routes that Gilmore got
washed out that couldn't get through the
wash across the field Landry was wide
open Parker was wide open that you'd
think Brown would do the same if not
Jude Smiths Schuster what do you think
Willie every time they've met I mean
he's been a nightmare averaging about a
hundred yards receiving yards every time
they played so of course they got to
figure out how to slow him down I don't
think you stopped I had sent me a burn I
think you got to figure out how to slow
him down and you want to rich when you
when you watch the tape there are a lot
of missed Ackles a lot of breakdowns and
assignments and mental errors and and
and that's what we saw from this
deepness the first four weeks um you
know players would rake right in the
middle of the gap guys could not just
with miss he breaks a long run there
were some one-on-one coverage with with
Drake out of the backfield that the
linebackers for whatever reason
literally get behind them he catches the
ball four big plays receivers running
through free and miscommunications on
the back end things that we thought that
his defense had made adjustments and and
fixed that those problems came back up
to my
so I'm sure that all the tape that
they're saying like the breakdowns that
they had defensively they're going to
give back to business they're going to
probably break things down it's going to
be a total different game plan going in
this week against Pittsburgh which is a
more demure office I mean they're way
more it's supposed to have been Miami so
they know they have their hands full if
they make critical errors a mistake
that's going to continue to turn in a
big play Willie McGinest here in the
Rich Eisen show knowing Brady as well as
you do what to what do you attribute his
last three weeks statistical slow down
to Willie last game he played terrible
he knows that you know he was
competitive and he beats herself down
and then there was just throws that
wasn't even close you know to the target
we said a lot had to do with the
breakdowns or front you know with the
protection and you got to give Miami
credit they did a great job like when
they have those passion routes which a
pressure rot is when you get that
pressure Rob said he depends they're
going to be open they did a good job of
taking that away they get a good they
did a good job of not letting the
receivers on the outside cooks and all
go to those guys off the line so when
Wade he got in trouble the guys that he
wanted to release the balls who was it
open there wasn't there they doing the
time and off and when when he did have
receivers open
he just wasn't all point he wasn't
accurate and you know that's the fewest
points to school at all year long and
statistically one of his worst game so I
had respect to see that again
I know I blade he is I know how sick to
his stomach he was out to that game and
how he's going to make adjustments how
he understands how big this game is
coming in to Pittsburgh and basically
this game is going to be a pop
atmosphere and it's going to it's going
to be the team that wins would be the
team that has home-field well I think
you know we're always driving at two
there though Willie is that at some
point we're going to see some
diminishing returns due to age right I
mean you can only you can only play at a
goat level for a certain
span of time and he has done that and he
has set the bar higher that maybe no
one's ever gonna jump over but do you
think anything that we've seen over the
last three weeks of the struggles that
you said of being accurate or being able
to make certain throws is due to
anything that we might see as a canary
in a coal mine Willie no I don't because
before that we were talking about MVP
you know just a week ago where we're
talking about where it's Grady I had
Tony a band except the other people um
you know it would be the MVP of the
league so if this gives at the ministry
we wouldn't be having those
conversations and then you know I can go
out and point our tape of every single
quarterback and show you where they had
you know bad games or there wasn't
consistent or they missed calls from
that Ryan all the way down so I wouldn't
say that and I would say little finish
the season see how things turn out that
Brady's been consistent he's been
playing at a high level and then you
know teams other teams make adjustments
to you got to give them credit I think
he you know I have to be fit to die and
Teddy gets a really good quarterback um
you don't want to be that team for him
to go on out career days and pull all
these numbers in touch 2,000 yards so
teams make adjustments and and and they
have good games as well like we saw with
the Miami defense Willie McGinest of NFL
Network my compadre here on the Rich
Eisen show all right who do you think
McDaniels and Brady are circling on that
Pittsburgh defense and planning a
certain matchup problem for them who do
you think that is right now in the film
rooms this week Willie well the obvious
water stays he is not here he was one of
their better coverage guys you know he's
very athletic and coverage in his face
so I would be definitely targeting
spirits a guy who just started on Vince
Williams is that you know he's there's a
really good players that you want to
attack them in the cupboard side and a
lot of the success that the page's
office we had hot hand against
Pittsburghers to get those guys out of
the box don't allow them to crop the
blocks and bring those Blitz homes and
blitzes and put pressure on brady you
want to spray them out and you
you want to make them do things they're
not a customer daughter they really
don't like Jordan that's covered you so
you get those kind of guys out of the
box
I stick the running backs the goal
against my backers of course just coming
back and they've always had you know the
last three meetings once has had a lot
of success the safety or safety /live
doctor trying to cover him so that's
going to be a definite match up to look
out for as well all right so put me in
the defensive film room right now when
they put the tape on a brown and bell
what is Patricia thinking and talking to
his guys about this week well it starts
with Bill you know if you can't stop the
run game then it opens up everything
down the field so you you got to try and
make them wonder Mitchell and the
Patriots have had some success in doing
that that if you don't stop there you
don't have a choice the one thing
without Tony or blinders you just don't
want to give up those big explosive
plays so if you play tight Merrick
Edward you better have helped over the
top he runs great routes
he runs every single route they move him
around and do a great job of trying to
find those mismatches whether he's
outside or inside or they got him in
motion so he's going to have this
catches rich and you know you can't
expect to stop him you just don't going
to give up those explosive plays I think
in three meetings Wildheart one touch
now but he's averaged 100 yards
receiving so they're immersed in he's
going to have catches but just try and
keep them out of the end zone and then
we're there the same way um don't let
him get going in the running game and as
a receiver um you got to figure out how
not to give him those one-on-one
matchups either because he's wondering
better receivers even though he's
playing a running back position
ask him a poll question hey Willie which
team most needs to be the number one
seed in the AFC Steelers are Pats do you
think I would probably say Pittsburgh
because they have an answer chef's go to
New England winning and I think they
play better if you watched their track
look over this past season they stand
there a little bit on the roll they
don't care as well on the road so if you
talk about 10:00 at atmosphere on the
highest field and having to cry on you
and you look at what they've done at
home
where's Russia's losses in a success
rate almost a pitch that would probably
need to need to have that home game
what's your relationship would snoop
like this week Willie you know that we
was we was down there Saturday and our
youth football arm championships and we
got the we got to have a little
conversation you know about about the
game we didn't really get into a novel
way that he was he was he was feeling
good about itself I mean he was feeling
real good about itself mm-hmm well he's
got a Long Beach Poly guy on his team
right now right in Smiths Shuster right
Willie he does it gives him a little
more room for that I've been checking
out his Instagram it has just been all
Spillers everyday some Stiller's going
up maybe two or three times a day
something still is is getting posted so
he may even be at the game I'm not sure
we haven't talked okay yet but he was
thinking about going down for the game
all right Willie you take care of always
love chatting with you okay I'll see you
at the shop I already said it you're the
man Willie McGinest so Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience